I don't know how big your P I understand
Scott has a Warhammer oh that he's got
like a real I'm a grower not a shower
nice dude but it grows to a nice I I
mean I guess I don't know I don't I've
been told this is so funny because it's
like we're bullying him for having a big
dick and getting [__] this is this OPP
this the opposite of like Middle
School like when you get sober it's like
oh what are you still getting [__] and
drinking and doing drugs you [__]
idiot like everything is flipped on his
head like we're so washed that we're
like dude stop dude stop having a big
ass dick and having an awesome time and
getting
[Laughter]
[__] that's what being 40s like